what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Venom so let's just get
right into it because this is a really
really cool story now we did finish
volume one but that was a little while
ago so as a little bit of a recap and if
you really want the whole thing make
sure you check out the Venom playlist
where you can get caught up on volume
one all this really happened up to this
point is that in the aftermath of King
and black Eddie Brock became the new
really the new king and black himself
meaning he could control all symbiotes
Across the Universe now in doing this it
basically required him to leave his son
Dylan behind on Earth so Eddie could
serve a greater purpose he left the main
symbiote behind and told it to keep an
eye on Dylan but told Dylan not to merge
with the Symbiote and so over the course
of the story different events transpired
that ultimately led to Dylan bonding
with the Symbiote in order to basically
escape with his life because at that
point in time you had two groups that
were hunting after Dylan and the
Symbiote itself the first is the life
Foundation led by Carlton Drake which
has long since been trying to hunt down
and track symbiotes and use them for
their own ends and the other part of
this is alcamax which is a really shady
organ organization led by Liz Allen
that's basically trying to do the same
thing but for a different purpose the
long and short of this is that Dylan's
basically being hunted continually by
two different groups who want to kill
him and take his Symbian and so 13 days
after the end of volume 1 we pick up
here where Dylan is in the care of a guy
named Jake now Jake is cool because Jake
leads a group of bikers called the
Renegades but he's kind of retired from
being a biker if there is such a thing
the important thing about him is that he
ran a pretty hardcore group back in the
day they did all kinds of crazy things
but the reality is over time he's just
sort of walked away from it all and so
he effectively retired from it and he
really kind of runs this section of a
town now there is a rival gang called
the hellhounds that are actually trying
to take over the territory of Jake and
his retired biker gang now one of the
things that had gone on here is that
someone had attacked lens forces the guy
who runs the hellhounds now of course
just by virtue of the comic we know that
it was Dylan who did it but Jake doesn't
know right at the end of the day he just
kind of has Dylan taking care of the bar
itself and can an eye on things and
making sure he does a series of small
tasks and whatnot to earn his keep while
Jake is taking care of him but the funny
thing here is Jake's also pretty jaded
because the reality is that Dylan
approaches the area with a kind of
youthful maybe a bit of naivety in the
sense of like we can make this place
better but in a lot of ways in a lot of
ways Jake is succumbed to his life
experience and saying like if you go out
there and you fight that kind of fight
against guys who want to tear towns
apart or something along those lines all
that's going to get you is like a bum
leg right he's like I've got a blown out
eardrum it causes you nothing but
problems so lay low enjoy your life and
and call it a day it's one of the
interesting things because it runs in
stark contrast to everything that Dylan
had been taught by Eddie which is really
the kind of lesson Peter learned from
Uncle Ben with great power must also
come great responsibility and so if
Dylan can do something he has the
responsibility to do something hence the
reason why he attacked the forces of the
hellhounds because he's kind of dabbling
in superhero Antics to a degree getting
his feet wet and what it means to be a
good guy now for Lynn him self he
actually drags one of his guys into his
office and they start spewing all this
stuff which as far as Lin is concerned
is a bunch of Babylon nonsense about how
some monster or alien attacks them the
alien they saw on the news and different
things like that Lynn doesn't take it
seriously and in fact goes after or
really has this guy taken away and
basically eliminated for the most part
is you know in no uncertain terms he
then tells his guys get out there do
whatever you have to do give me some
answers and I don't care what happens
and so while there is a little bit of
discussion between the Venom symbiote
and Dylan as to whether or not they
should even stay in this town and really
Dylan wants to right because he's like
we can protect this town the Venom
symbiote is just like no let's leave
it's not our responsibility to save
every small town out there in existence
now to a degree the symbiote's not
entirely wrong right if every superhero
tried to protect every town that exists
in the United States nothing would ever
get done because there's just not enough
manpower to do it and so ultimately
Dylan just kind of boxes the Symbiote in
and is like you are tasked by my dad to
protect me so I'm going down there now
what or not you go down there with me is
entirely up to you but there's a there's
fires being set out there there's
innocent people in this town we have to
do something because the hellhounds are
ripping the whole place up and so while
you do have Jake and his forces where
he's literally just like nope whatever
goes on out there we're not having
anything to do with it we're protecting
ours and our own this leads to basically
Venom stepping in and attacking all
these guys right attacking the forces of
uh of the hellhounds now while that's
going on Bedlam sees all of it and
Bedlam heads to the direction of where
dillenbrock is now Bedlam was introduced
in volume one he's basically a new
symbiote we don't really know a whole
lot about him and in fact we'll talk a
little more about his character here in
a minute I'm not going to leave you guys
hanging in terms of information about
him I do want to wrap up this stuff with
with Dylan pretty quickly but that
basically leads to Dylan of course
facing off against the hellhounds there
is a situation or there is a point where
Jake comes head to head with Len the
leader of the hellhounds and they kind
of invoke the old school way of doing
things which is we both lead to rival
factions you and I as the leaders will
fight if you knock me down and I stay
down right you knocked me out or kill me
or whatever then you'd get to do
whatever you want here right but if I
stand up you leave this town and you
leave my guys alone it's one of the
interesting things because I don't know
if that's truly a biker standpoint but I
will say there is a little bit of Honor
in that and so ultimately the two of
them do end up fighting each other but
ultimately Len gets the upper hand on
Jake and then Lynn kills Jake and so
that's when lens forces get to basically
do whatever it is that they want to do
now the crazy thing about this is that
while all this is happening and Dylan is
trying to make his way to Jake in order
to protect him that Bedlam makes his
move on Dylan and attacks him and
overpowers him incredibly fast now under
any normal circumstance this would be
something that you would expect right
Dylan is far less experienced in using
the Venom symbiote than Eddie Brock ever
was but the truth about this is the
Venom Symbian has all the experience of
Eddie Brock and so what the symbia does
is basically tell Dylan let me run the
show I will deal with this guy but even
the Venom symbiote is overcome by Bedlam
and that's no small thing because the
Venoms to be it's gone Toe to Toe with
some pretty head Heavy Hitters and the
fact that Dylan or really the Symbiote
itself is being overpowered by Bedlam is
an astonishing feat now the Symbiote
does ultimately get the upper hand in
the sense that it stabs Bedlam through
the head and then basically walks away
but this is Dylan's inexperience in
realizing symbiotes can heal from that
kind of stuff either that or he
recognizes that's the case but believes
that in going to deal with uh with Jake
and his forces it'll buy him time to get
that whole situation sorted out and then
come back to Bedlam the problem here is
that with Jake having been killed by Len
that now Jake's forces it's open season
Lin's guys opened fire Jake's forces are
gone and so in this moment when Dylan is
watching all of this happen he literally
gets there just a day late and a dollar
short Bedlam jumps back into The Fray
and attacks Dylan and then overpowers
them and then literally starts punching
a hole in him and then tells him like
pain makes you stronger pain makes you
better look upon my face and no pain and
that's when we find out that Bedlam is
actually Eddie Brock now here's the cool
thing behind this right because there's
a lot more going on on here than were
initially led to belief so what this
does is this jumps back to Eddie himself
now remember when Eddie had basically
died in volume 1 when he had contacted
Dylan and said meet me at this location
and we will try to get you to a safe
place when he was killed in an explosion
sabotage essentially that he woke up in
this place called The Garden which over
time he learned housed other symbiotes
which were basically Kings and black
from different points in time or we
didn't necessarily know exactly what was
going on with them they were just other
individuals who would go on to take
control of the Venom symbiote and all of
it was led by a guy named Meridius who
is exceedingly ambiguous we knew nothing
about him and we still don't know
anything about him he's just a guy who's
there we know nothing about this dude
but the entirety of the garden is
composed of symbiote matter and was
created by Meridius himself so whatever
role this guy plays he is exceedingly
powerful when it comes to being able to
use the Symbiotes themselves all Eddie
Brock's been able to do as the king in
black is basically look through the eyes
of all symbiotes that exist Across the
Universe this guy Maria is controls them
all he can do anything he wants with
them all it's a pretty astonishing feat
but of course Eddie keeps having these
visions of basically Dylan being in
danger or Dylan being attacked or
something along those lines and it sends
him into a panic attack because the
truth about this is Eddie doesn't
necessarily know where he is but he
can't escape where he is and so because
it sends him into a panic attack he
actually breaks free of the garden and
then falls through space and time and
lands in an unknown location and so what
goes on here is the suit itself
seemingly adapts to the place that he's
in where it starts feeding him
information the way a computer would
right it feeds back and answers him the
way a computer would but he's basically
told that that the location that he's at
is on Earth and that it's the 60
134th cycle and that in Marvel Comics a
cycle on Earth is basically a year he's
in the year sixty thousand the 602nd
century and he's just like okay this is
crazy right like so obviously the garden
exists outside of space and time and so
this is it's wild because as he's making
his way through here of course he's set
upon by a whole bunch of of forces that
tell him to surrender the Symbiote
itself for the conqueror's glory and so
as he makes his way through this ship
after defeating all these guys he ends
up coming across King the Conqueror the
guy who runs this entire area and it's a
really really amazing moment because as
far as I'm aware in Marvel Comics venom
has never fought Kang and I don't even
know if he's ever actually met Kang and
that seems to be the case here because
Kang agrees Eddie Brock and it's just
like I know who you are and in fact
there comes a point where you and I meet
and I end up becoming one of your oldest
friends so yes you are going to live far
beyond a normal human life and there's a
little more going on there and Kang will
explain that we'll get a little further
into this as time goes on but it's one
of these things where Eddie Rock just
refers to Kang as this guy that the
Avengers fight sometimes so they never
really have a history together this is
cool it's really really exciting because
what happens I mean if this was Venom
from like 1998 in Marvel Comics I'd say
yeah man he's gonna get curves thumped
by Kane the Conqueror Kane the Conqueror
the guy who can manipulate time yeah
Venom doesn't have a chance but this is
Venom from in 2022 going into 2023 this
is a guy who operates on a universal
level he stands a much better chance
against Kang than he ever did and that's
the funny thing is because what Kang
does is immediately attack Venom now
it's more of a lesson than anything else
that Kang's not really fighting to kill
he's trying to push the capabilities of
Eddie Brock in how he uses his Venom
Simeon and he even says that you look at
the world through linear time and you
look at your symbiote in a very basic
way we're going to fix that and so as
they're fighting each other Venom or
Eddie Brock faces off against King using
the same kind of of fighting style that
he would normally use if he were
fighting Spider-Man or for some reason
he were fighting Captain America
Conventional Weapons based on how he
perceives the world but Kang constantly
pushing him and forcing him to think
outside the box that what he does is he
actually uses the Symbiote to conjure or
to create the same kind of weapon that
Kang is using and this is when he starts
to think differently now this is a huge
moment when it comes to the Venom
Symbian it's easy to look at this it's
just like yeah it's Venom fighting Kang
cool whatever this is an instance where
what Al Ewing is establishing is that
Eddie Brock can use the Symbiote to
conjure arms and Armament that are
comparable to the person he's facing off
against so the question that you could
ask yourself and this is where the door
has been open to this if Venom's facing
off against like the Silver Surfer for
example Kenny conjure his own silver
surfboard can he make a surfboard that's
comparable to the silver surface not
equal in power because the Silver Surfer
is powered by the power Cosmic and it
seems like Eddie Brock can't necessarily
duplicate that but it is a phenomenal
thing it's a really it just kind of
pushes this shape-shifting abilities
Beyond taking on the physical form of
something and in fact taking on the
properties of the thing that he that
he's using and so in his fight against
Kang of course Kang gets the upper hand
and that's what he basically tells Venom
what you did in doing this is the first
step that you're taking into a much
larger World sure the weapon that you
conjured was just a symbiote version of
the weapon that I used and so it was not
equal to my weapon in power but over
time it will be over time your abilities
will will expand and they will grow and
so what he says is if you'll excuse me
we'll get back to this but I have to go
to the to the little boy conquerors room
and so literally steps into his office
and he's met by Meridius and what all
this seems to be Eddie Brock meeting
Kang this all seems to be the plan of
Meridius himself again a very ambiguous
character we don't really know anything
about this guy and so what it does is it
picks up really with like a training
session with Kank and this is why I say
man this is so cool Kang sits down and
trains Eddie Brock and what he says is
okay much like what I told you before
you're stepping into a much larger world
you are now using your symbiote to not
only allow you to dodge the spider sense
of Spider-Man different things like that
but to take on the properties and
principles of various things that you
can duplicate in a lot of ways Eddie
Brock is learning to use the Symbiote to
become very similar to like Vanessa
Carlisle right a copycat from Marvel
Comics copycat is very similar to
Mystique in the sense that she can
shape-shift and take on the forms of
other people that difference between
copycat and Mystique is that Mystique
can only copy their form copycat can
copy their powers but where Kang is kind
of helping to push the understanding of
Eddie Brock in terms of his physical
Powers he's also doing this in his
relation to understanding time now one
of the things that Kang is doing here is
he's actually trying to allude to Eddie
something bigger is going on he's not
being obvious about it he's kind of
handing him these these little bitty
Clues but he's helping Eddie piece the
picture or piece the puzzle together of
what's going on with Meridius without
saying hey man so like here's exactly
what's unfolding a lot of this seems to
be predicated on the idea that if Kang
did that Meridius would kill him but one
of the things that came to conqueror
does and this is a genius maneuver by Al
Ewing because one of the things that he
says and really answers is the question
why doesn't Kang just go back in time
and like stop Steve Rogers from getting
the super soldier serum kill Abraham
Erskine early and like deactivate the
bomb or like push the Incredible Hulk or
a Bruce Banner out of the way of the
gamma bomb so he never becomes the
Incredible Hulk destroy the or kill the
spider that would bite Peter Parker why
doesn't he like go back in time and do
these little things that stop different
superheroes from coming into existence
and this is answered as king is
explaining time to Venom and saying
there are some things that happen in
this universe that you can't stop
there's no conceivable way you can keep
that from happening that much like Reed
Richards finding the Council of reeds
and Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four
Peter Parker will always be bitten by a
radioactive spider if Kane the Conqueror
were to go back in time and stop the
spider from biting Peter Parker he would
just be bitten by a different one he may
become a different version of Spider-Man
but he will always become Spider-Man
Steve Rogers always becomes Captain
America that's seemingly how these
things always work now this is largely
alewing ignoring stories like House of M
for example where where Steve Rogers
never becomes Captain America so it's
largely all you and kind of ignoring
that and focusing more on how things
transpire in the main Marvel Universe
but with this information what Eddie
Brock realizes is that him transitioning
from the garden to the 602nd century in
Kang ship means he can travel through
time he can move back and forth through
time but one of the things that Kang
tells him is understand that when you
move back and forth through time it's
like having invisible rubber bands on
you it's always going to try to pull you
back from where you left right so Kane
the Conqueror for example when he leaves
the 31st century and goes to like the
20th century time is always trying to
pull him back to the 31st Century
because of his technology and his
understanding of time he knows how to
work around that limitation Eddie Brock
does not and so as a result of this
Eddie Brock actually leaps into the time
stream and this is when we end up
finding out a lot of the things that are
going on here are happening because of
what Eddie Brock had done for example
Archer Lyle who meets up with uh with
Dylan and then ultimately betrays him
Archer Lyle just arrives where Dylan is
in volume 1 because Eddie Brock traveled
back in time and sent her an email
telling her you need to go find Dylan
that's the reason why Archer appeared
out of nowhere Eddie sent her there now
of course Eddie was under the belief
that because he and Archer were such
close contacts back when he was a
reporter that Archer was still a good
guy effectively Archer turned against
Dylan and tried to hand him over to the
life Foundation of course following
Dylan's capture in volume 1 when Eddie
appears out of nowhere and kind of this
mangold's conglomerate of like different
symbiote forms and starts talking to
Dylan that was Eddie transitioning
through time and arriving in that moment
only to find Dylan is basically being
held by the life Foundation after being
handed over by Archer Lyle and that's
when Eddie learns Archer betrayed Dylan
which is something that he never thought
was really going to happen now what's
also ironic about this is that he in
turn basically tells Dylan I can fix all
of this for the moment I will free you
but you are going to have to find a way
out of here right you're gonna have to
get out of here on your own and so what
happens is traveling back through time
he finds a body or a version of himself
that's just waiting to be taken right
there's a moment in time when his body's
just laying in a bed which is the
perfect time for him to inhabit that
body that is the body or that's the the
Eddie Brock that called Dylan in volume
one and said meet me at this location
now of course the funny thing about this
is that at that point in time in volume
1 there were were two Eddie Brocks
walking around one of them was the Eddie
Brock that called Dylan up on the phone
and says immediately don't say the name
don't say Dad right just tell me that
you found it and everything's okay there
was another Eddie Brock that was walking
through the house this version of Eddie
here in this moment right now traveling
through time realized the version of
himself that was walking through the
house was actually Meridius pretending
to be Eddie Brock and so once he
realized that that's why he told his son
do not say the word dad otherwise
Meridius will realize that you're
talking to me and he'll kill you or
he'll immediately come after me but
things won't happen as they're supposed
to now of course once that call is made
and he's expected to go meet Dylan of
course he does that's when he basically
perishes or appears to die and that's
effectively it right he wakes up in the
garden but of course at this point as
he's traveling through time Meridius
realizes what he's doing and literally
grabs Eddie himself and throws him and
locks him inside the mind of the Bedlam
civilian and so Eddie Brock is
witnessing everything the Bedlam
symbiote is doing as it's attacking
Dylan when Dylan was trying to save Jake
at the beginning meaning of this story
and that's what's crazy is because
that's when Eddie realizes the Bedlam
symbiote is himself but it's it's Eddie
Brock when he was like the steroid
abusing Eddie Rock back in the 1990s in
Marvel Comics and so this is a really
cool moment because what Al Ewing does
is he takes all this information and he
reconciles it together that there comes
a point when as Eddie Brock is watching
Bedlam attack his son Eddie Brock
absolutely screams and manages to escape
the mind of bedlam and wake up in the
garden but when he does he emerges as
Finnegan so if you guys remember in
volume 1 you had one of the kings in
Black who seemed like a fool he seemed
kind of stupid right a little bit of an
idiot and he in turn like was attacked
by Bedlam Bedlam hated him and then just
kind of sent flying that was Eddie Brock
right that was Eddie Brock escaping the
mind of bedlam and so what ends up
happening here because I know a lot of
you guys are probably a little confused
you're like all right there's a lot
that's going on here what Meridius does
and what alewing does is he explains all
of it and he says all these different
Kings and black Here Eddie are you
they're just different points in your
life Finnegan is the version of you who
comes to this realization after I
explain it to you that they are all you
he's the version of you that's insane
because you can't handle the truth of
what I've told you it's why you seem so
goofy and so silly that Alum is the
version of you that experiences anger
and rage you eventually transition
Beyond Bedlam into another one and into
another one and into another one until
you eventually become me I am the end
result of what you will become that you
have all these different paths right you
have seven paths seven stages that
you're going to go through now here's a
kicker about this is because what
Meridius tells Eddie is that I am your
sixth version right I am the final
version of you but Eddie realizes
there's seven paths which mean Beyond
Meridius right after Meridius the most
evil version of of himself that Eddie is
going to find another version of himself
seemingly the most powerful version of
himself that he becomes there is a
seventh symbiote that exists out there
what form that takes what version that
is we do not know but seemingly it is
beyond anything and everything that
makes Meridius what he is what level of
power this will be I have no clue but
what I will tell you guys I am excited
to find out the work of Al Ewing is
amazing here it's it's probably one of
the greatest runs on Venom that I think
I've ever seen but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace